Somaly coma rahmatullahi wa barakatuh
here at the scene of a crime were a
vicious terrorist attack actually took
place and we shouldn't shy away from
calling this a terrorist attack just
because it was unsuccessful in killing
the people that the people admirers
tried to kill if someone for example the
Westminister bomber tried to order those
guys who ran over the individuals in
Westminister
they missed their targets they'd still
be labeled as terrorists and nested in
the same way these individuals here
despite the fact that they didn't manage
to kill anyone certainly were plotting a
terrorist attack which Dillinger three
individuals
critically and we're here at the scene
of that crime and one of the things here
at the surface area where the Shia sect
obviously occupied this in the air this
area and we want to show that despite
the fact that we're sudden is obviously
here we have ideological differences
with the Shia that at points of you know
when when there is actually physical
harm when there's injustice when there
is when people's lives are at risk we
must show our support to every community
that fills that injustice whether it's
the Shia community or Ahmadiyya
community or the Sikh community or the
Christian community or the Jewish
community or the atheist community
whoever is as Muslims are Sunni Muslims
we must we really must show that it's
not something to do with religion it's
more to do with a universal matter of
Justice which we must uphold as a matter
of our religion do you want to add to
this yes so I would say also something
very important which is that this was
exactly this wasn't an act off it was a
hate crime
all right people injured and reality is
that we should not judge an act by the
people harmed but rather by the intent
of the personal carried out that for
this person intended to attack Muslims
and as Muslims we would stand together
with any religious group regardless of
their religious background or
inclination so theologies or whatever
you call it the point being is that
where is that there is a muscle ha a
benefit for Islam the Muslims then we
should stand hand too
and with these people and ensure the
muscle had the benefit of Islam and the
Muslims and as brother Mohammed
Azharuddin mentioned yes there are
certain differences he laughs at Arcadia
certain theological differences which
are irreconcilable in future this is of
course the consensus understand I want a
man we don't shy away from that evident
but rather we are here for a different
reason Allah Allah Allah says which our
own ability will talk about well that's
our only other one and Allah so Allah
says and United those upon justice and
said I do not unite upon transgression
and sin and this is mukluks one of my
measure of the most and I bird said this
is not luck it is absolute irrespective
of a person's religious background it
could be a non-muslim if there is a
benefit from Islam and the Muslims just
like children football in the time of
jahiliya and maybe some Allah or any who
was seldom witnessed and he said if it
were here now I would have witnessed it
again if you were here now I would have
witnessed it again so wherever there is
justice then we should also take part in
that and Allah Allah Allah knows best if
you save one Saudis as if you save the
whole of humanity the whole of humanity
now the reason we're here is because we
want to prevent this we don't want this
happen again and in order for us to do
this we need to bring this to lights of
the people because if we do not and if
we just brushes under the copy it's
gonna start to stink stink and smell and
that's what's happening it happened with
history Park Darrin Osborn who was
watching far-right propaganda they
checked his daughter's iPad and they
found in motion Britain first and Tony
Robinson's videos not only that in his
letter he quotes it to me Robinson why
is this happening this is hatred hatred
breeds hatred and that's why you will
have which we're going to have accounts
of the people who actually lived and saw
this for themselves
well can I approach them in a minute but
before I do that in sha Allah why would
I do that you want to vote maybe telling
reporters they're doing their job we
just wanted to speak to them and find
out are they reporting this as a
terrorist incident or a hate crime if
somebody's want to find that why and
also we just want to go to the brothers
on that side and find out because some
of them will never get in hits we went
here from their mouth of exactly what's
happened so just follow me in shallow an
awesome question we ask you some
questions in ten minutes
no no no I'm sorry I've really soon okay
okay so after you go live you can't ask
me any questions or - yeah just that's
what I want
no no just YouTube is where youtubers
okay you know you're reporting there's a
terrorist incident right no could it
just to help you rehearse oh it's a
terrorist incident by the way maybe you
might miss that point there I don't care
if they Rachel naki this is so what
we're going to do now is we're going to
go and find out from these brothers here
who they witnessed it their self exactly
why but let's go find out what exactly
happened here well where are they where
are the brothers
okay so basically this this is I think
this is exactly what happened can we do
it here simply yeah we're not gonna be
able to hear us we'll make it clear okay
so basically the guys with witness say
they're coming now it's gone away for
the mashaallah they're coming so we're
gonna hear it from them exactly they
were here they're at the incident one of
them actually said himself that the car
literally nearly missed him and hits an
old man and broke his legs yeah so we're
gonna find out from the mashaallah we're
just waiting for them to come
okay so you was so this is one of the
problems who was here he was here yeah
okay so what what exactly happened that
what was going on before what happened I
didn't mean to amplify sorry yeah after
the lecture yeah so you you use an
electron you live yeah yeah Drazen
walking so my car's parked up there but
you can imagine a lot of people coming
out at the same time so the left has
done the lectures done you so everyone's
coming out woman in kids yeah and the
wrong horse men and woman a woman on
that side so it was mostly men here yeah
but as we're coming out we then get to
you see what that brown building is
there yeah the brown building yeah yeah
there's a side road there anyway cut the
story short as we get there we're
hearing like a loud car sound then where
was a collie from did it come from man
from there from that road there so we
came from there yeah okay so we're
hearing people shine stop him stop him
we're trying to hit the car one one
security guy hits the car breaks the
window he's in front of me mother
friends behind me I've kind of put two
and two together and thought wait a
minute this could be something like a
terrorist attack yeah
which is nowadays wrong and we didn't
realize at the time I've seen like in
front of us when except when there's
like a little gap between a van and a
golf right there obviously just pushed
him into the middle of the at that
moment we wasn't 100% sure he's coming
for us
okay I didn't take no risks as I'm
pushing him into that gap the car's gone
faced us and gone for four hours
yeah so we literally I didn't act that
moment yeah we would have all been gone
so then hamdullah Trumbo
I didn't write good as we get to the
tonight there yeah he's just missed us
my other friends jumped out the way next
year you know the yeah so then he's
turned on to the that side of the road
maybe four or five guys young old man he
goes into the black dominoes literally
broke just takes them all out then he
starts were then left fry on to this guy
that guy so all of us are just we're
just stressing about here well that was
the scariest part running behind the car
yeah trying to catch up to this always
death and you just in survival mode
you're trying to save as many people as
possible and you just act quickly Bo and
that's what happened and then as they
got to this side of hoodie here I think
another two three people here but broad
the fact no one's dead it's a miracle
there's no one driving to Jason no no no
this guy wasn't trying to get away he
was trying to hit people yeah bro he was
directing the car left right trying to
hit people so yeah man that's why that's
what happened some kind of altercation
with these guys between drugs or
something yeah apparently I don't know
too much about it but apparently today
we heard that the car is a stolen car
with a stolen number plate wait a minute
whew if you're parking up to smoke a
joint and have a drink why sitting do
nine up on a stolen car I mean
yeah I mean I was opened it could be
anything but I was he was flying his
name obviously he was trying to get
people and he turned him the right he
knew what he was doing so they know
Clausen is a terrorist attack there's no
question you like when a Muslim birthday
they don't care he's when is it done the
fact that he was gonna speak to the lady
she saying oh she's busy now we're gonna
go as Peter no matter how busy she is
it's like if a Muslim done this it's at
they don't care they're not gonna say oh
we do a way for what the police said how
we feel I don't if at breakfast today
it's gonna be you know a terrorist
attack but when it's done towards
Muslims it's okay then they [ __ ] away
so is anything else you want to say no
this is exactly our point you get it
killing innocent people for political
real do it and you type what to
terrorism and that's what it means but
the issue here is the political part I'm
not sure
yeah was he trying to prepare people
yeah he was yes a hundred percent was
fine there the question that least
losses well I buy it I felt terror
yes fellows yes exactly they go and the
most terrifying part of it is after he's
just missed us and he's going for
everyone else and what key did you bro
Leighton waited again he gets caught I
personally have no doubt if this guy's
been watching far-right material just
like their own husband Dan wasn't when
he was caught they checked his
daughter's iPad they found is watching
Britain first Tommy Robinson all this
kind of stuff these guys are just like
Isis what like they are the same side
they the same coin from the other side
and they both feed off each other when
Isis carry out an attack the far I love
it they're like a supposed to agenda
when the far-right character Isis love
it then I wrote this is what they want
to do to the Muslims this is how it is
and this way we're gonna speak to the
journalist hopefully and see what she
says do you have a minute
we just wanted to ask basically are you
reporting this as a hate crime or as a
terrorist attack we're using the same
terminology that the police use which is
a hate okay so I'm a bleep many but I'm
not gonna go you guys but I just want to
ask dragging you guys in the media
I mean question is just like when a
Muslim carries a taco you don't find him
for me no you guys but the media
generally they just call it as a it's a
terrorist I don't know what's the
difference between hate crime in a
terrorist attack
oh very careful that we use the
terminology that the police use okay so
that's where we get our cue say we're
treating as a terror incident okay so we
need to question the police and not you
guys we say if the police say it's okay
but personally to you would you say this
was a terrorist attack or a hate crime
that me personal he said okay I don't I
don't blame you Suzanne they're doing a
job but I don't need to say much the
focus is and I'm not talking about them
generally I'm just talking about in in
general the focus of the media and the
police is very clear you know if this
was a Muslim there is no ifs or buts
about it it's a terrorist attack you
know physically Park this happened we
went at the middle of the night we had
to put pressure up pressure pressure and
then he was called a terrorist attack
you know I'm not saying we did it bound
you saying that pressure that was put we
need to do the same provinces if you're
watching this video make sure this goes
viral
this can be your mom your dad your
sister you'll your kids don't think okay
it's not me I'm okay in my comfy bed
this can happen to you has happened
before it's time I [ __ ] attacks are on
the rise if you don't do something about
it believe me you're going to be next so
do something about inshallah we want you
guys insha'Allah to share this video
with your friends and family and do not
let this go under the carpet do not
because this carry on
so he shall I hope you guys have
benefited I don't know the police are
not here for me to talk to them but
share this with your friends and family
assalamu alaikum